when you play doom it just it feels
different we've taken the essence of
doing the DNA of doom and said how does
how does this translate for a modern
shooter audience it's exciting it
creates that feel that is unique to us
and you know that's why we do this is to
create experiences that are that are
unique and are something that is
distinctly ours it starts with combat
the fluidity of movement the speed of
movement using your guns in really
effective ways and feeling connected to
the weapons the responsiveness of the
weapons Doom is about about guns first
and foremost and you know fighting
demons with guns
I think the designer sure did a great
job I mean they really tried to make
each weapon distinct each one kind of
has its own style to it for example the
shotguns kind of an
up-close-and-personal weapon but you can
modify it so it has an alternate fire
that can you can it works from a
distance you're inspired to keep playing
because you want to fill up that full
arsenal and you're also fighting into
the full suite of characters that we
have in the game in each of those
characters are kind of like a chess
piece so once the chessboard is full in
the later levels and your arsenal is
full then you can kind of pick and
choose and tailor your experience to
your certain play style with just the
weapons alone the way that you play is
is one of the most fun parts about doing
this seems to agree with you we've kind
of had this whole upgrade system that
allows you to play in a lot of different
ways and use you know your own strategy
and how you approach the different
arenas and and you know even tweak that
as you go through the game
then there's the progression items like
the research projects that we have and
the runes each of those basically allow
you to customize your your character and
the way the game plays in the way it
feels
I like to tell them my experience to
speed make it so I could glory kill
faster I can mantle faster I can switch
mods faster I can do all these things
just a little bit faster and once you
stack these things on top of each other
the game just plays even faster than it
already does which out the boxes it's
pretty pretty fast so but that's my
personal playstyle
a lot of games have kind of execution
moves because the game is so fast-paced
it was a nice way to get out of what
kind of happens with the clunkiness of
some melee systems and and and make
melee within the doom franchise
something that that really is very doom
it's a contextual anywhere that you look
you actually glory do a different glory
kill on a character so if I approach
character from behind I'll do a certain
type of glory kill and it all feels very
fluid I've played the game for a crazy
amount of time and I still love doing it
it's not a casual game where you can
kind of you know be doing something else
while you play especially in the arenas
you know they're very challenging and
I'm in the best possible way we fill
these these spaces in these combat
encounters with with such a nice
diversity of enemies that are so
distinct in their each of their
behaviors it's kind of like a mental
chess game that's happening at a million
miles an hour you can turn the corner
there's a bank uvas you're probably
gonna want to switch to a chain gun or a
rocket launcher or Gauss cannon or
whatever is your favorite heavy type
weapon all these things are kind of
happening really fast and it makes for
an incredibly engaging experience
doom you kind of you got to sit up and
your chair a little bit and shake out
your hands
you know you get beat a couple times and
you're like okay this time I got it